and i i find it fascinating that uh this
article from newsweek is it's all bright
and the image they show just shows like
a a nice blue sky when the reality of
these videos is actually horrifying they
say shanghai residents scream from
windows get drone lockdown warnings
check this out i'm gonna i'm gonna play
this i hope you guys are ready for some
creepy sounds cause uh here we go
how do i get this to actually play
well apparently we can't go there we go
yeah there it is
[Music]
so there's a lot of people screaming
here's the crazier video check this one
out
this one is
shanghai residents go to their balconies
to sing and protest lack of supplies a
drone appears saying please comply with
code restrictions control your soul's
desire for freedom do not open the
window or sing
yo that echo is so creepy so i sent this
out to a friend said you know who speaks
mandarin and they said yeah that's
that's that's what the drone is telling
people control your soul's desire for
freedom welcome to the future my friends
how do you guys feel about it uh pretty
terrifying pretty terrifying no i mean
look i i think it's sad i think what's
really striking about this story isn't
just what's it's happening in china i
think it's the fact that
even without saying it there are some
number of americans who would have
absolutely no problem with this being
the policy in the united states we've
clearly given up any drive to have
freedom and it is sad to say that it
looks like there is a real chance the
lockdowns could be coming back
so a couple years ago
in august of 2020 these videos started
going around showing people screaming
when i first saw this video on twitter i
said somebody got hoaxed somebody
somebody uh took an old video and sent
it and said look what's going on in
china and it was a rerun it was it was
it was it was a replay this person
didn't do their due diligence
so i pulled up the old videos they're
different videos
so this is new and we have multiple
sources uh confirming this several news
outlets reporting on it and it appears
to be true because there's more than
just this one video there's apparently
dozens of videos the creepiest
that i have not verified but there have
been reports of people filming
taking their lives because there's no
food there's a video there's a video of
people fighting in a supermarket all the
store shelves are empty people have
taken garbage bags and they filled them
with whatever food they can and they
start fighting each other in the stores
i i always joke about this with the food
shortages you don't want to be in a
walmart parking lot fighting with agnes
over the cast over the last can of beans
and i mean it jokingly but watching
these videos of people in china fighting
over food in the supermarkets is scary
stuff man i mean it's reducing people
back to a primal state
where you gotta potentially kill
somebody to eat
i mean it's as primal as you can
possibly get and you ask yourself why
why would you ever push people to that
point
and i think i think the answer
unfortunately is that there's really not
multiple answers to that in my opinion
it is it is a purposeful way to crush
people to such a point you know it's the
nobody can lift their hand up for help
unless they're on the ground first
you know if the government if the people
in power want to say come on grab my
hand we'll save you you got to put them
on their knees before they're going to
reach up yeah and that if that is the
definition of putting them on their
knees to the maybe the ultimate way and
i think it's really uh
a dangerous thing for americans to say
that cannot possibly ever happen
in america really let somebody shut the
lights off for three months and see what
happens in america well i remember what
happened in new york during sandy and
and i i'm just going to stress this
point man
we're in rerun season guys because these
are the same conversations we had back
in 2020 with these lockdowns but i was
in new york when sandy hit
and the power goes out for an extended
period of time and there's people
standing outside of bodegas with like
clubs and bats
one person allowed in at a time i walk
in the store and the guy says all of the
perishables are spoiled don't take don't
don't buy them
the canned stuff and the and and you
know the like the sodas are fine but
they're warm there's no electricity so
it's like you can get you get cash only
honestly here in in north korea he
basically kim jong-un rules by
starvation he starves the populace they
have no strength literally no power
because they don't have any energy or
their lack of energy from lack of food
they're crawling around on the ground
looking for food people die on the side
bro this is from yunmi park who escaped
i've listened to her story escaped from
north korea escaped from that country
escaped that's the way they look at it
uh china it looks like this could be
i mean do they even care about the does
the ccp care about those people or do
they want less of them
they had the one child policy before
they wanted less people that way well
the only thing communists are good at
producing is human misery and food
shortages and then they just sit on top
and and revel in the what they have the
food because i'm thinking like oh
oh it's it's kim jong-un's got plenty of
food xi jinping's got plenty of food
right now they're really getting paid
they're central planners their view of
this is we don't care about the
individual we care about the machine and
if that means you've got a billion
people in china and they're thinking
this is so expensive and difficult to
maintain there's too many people here
so i'm sure they don't care when they're
looking at how can we streamline the
machine that is the chinese communist
party and this country the whatever they
want to call it
so you know the republic of china
people's republic of china if we want to
streamline this okay we can stand to get
rid of access
and then bring specialists in they don't
view the individuals that they starve
out they don't care they don't think
about it
yes and on top of that it's comple it's
totally impossible to centrally plan a
supply chain like that you just can't
know where resources should be allocated
without people being able to engage in
free trade one issue we saw during the
beginning or at the beginning of the
covet lockdowns is that even though food
production was considered an essential
service which wasn't shut down there
were still food shortages in some areas
we were getting less meat produced
because the packaging materials that
people use to send their meat to market
were considered non-essential so small
details like this are just going to
inevitably slip past politicians and the
bureaucrats they appoint to centrally
plan the economy so even if they're
making a good faith effort to get people
fed they're just not capable of doing so
right well and that there are
quantifiable facts in this country in
america
that that would lead you to believe the
only ending which is there are people
that want to see
food shortages happen in america a
couple of examples one they've been
paying farmers for the past two or three
years i'm from amarillo texas up in the
grain belt right through the middle of
there they're paying them
to to
literally mow down and bush hog their
soybean crops uh don't plant anything
this year leave it all alone and they're
like they're paying me more money to cut
up my soybeans than i would have made on
my soybeans so i'll cut up my soybeans
fdr what is it called fallowing fallow
why are they doing it you guys are
saying well they're getting government
checks to cut them up well why would the
government be doing well so there's
there's there's i could have the word
wrong so guys correct me if if i'm
getting this wrong i think it's can you
look it up fallow yeah and the idea is
something to do uh you know i honestly i
can't remember well it blends the
nutrients back down into the right right
if you grow something enough times you
kill you take everything out of the dirt
so they'll actually grow a crop and plow
it back under but we've been seeing uh
some of this for political reasons is
that what it is a fallow is usually
cultivated land that is allowed to lie
idle during the growth season right okay
so that's the re-neutralized system well
who owns more farmland right now than
any other individual bill gates why is
that what does he know about farming and
it's in the last few years i've been
buying it up and why did china start
buying corn futures like crazy over the
past two years
investors in the important context as uh
as for bill gates he may own the most as
an individual but it's not that much
relative to the grand scheme of total
available farmland so a lot of people
assume when they hear that it means like
half the country's owned by bill gates
no he owns a very tiny percentage of the
total but he bought he owns more than
any other individual
which still you know raises the question
why is this guy buying up farmland
what's he what's he what's he what's he
looking at in the future exactly an
investment what is it about food
production that he thinks is going to
become particularly lucrative very soon
here the people need to eat it yeah i
mean
people have always needed to eat that's
a little tongue-in-cheek that they're
shortages i know exactly i think he knew
or at least he saw it ahead maybe he
just saw it coming and he could he could
read the cards or maybe he knew you know
he's very connected i'm not playing
conspiracy here i don't know i think if
you've got a bunch of people
who uh you know bill gates has given
speeches on population
uh control
you know different from reduction but
you know i wonder about his thoughts on
that a lot of people speculate by all
means but uh uh control where he's he
talks about how we need to reduce the
amount of people being produced there's
too many so he's talked uh there's that
famous ted talk where he was like we can
reduce population growth by 10 or 15
percent
now when you got someone who's coming
out and talking like that why would i
trust that guy on health advice
yeah you're right i'm sorry i'm not i'm
not going to trust you on health advice
yeah that's his long-term goal
is to have fewer people
right exactly
i'm not saying he wants anybody to die
i'm just saying like i'm not going to
take health advice from a guy who sells
computers who talks about how there
should be less people and not just
not just health advice if if you're an
individual who doesn't believe that
human life is intrinsically valuable for
its own sake i'm not taking your advice
on anything there's no reason to listen
right he's a man he's like a utilitarian
mathematician i mean he's like a coding
guy and he's not a he's not a he wants
to be a renaissance man he's not i mean
i don't think he is he really
i don't know he's a salesman
i'm sure he knows computers he basically
co-opted a bunch of code in the early
80s and then made it private and sold it
that's right he didn't free the code he
did no he did the opposite he's the guy
that took richard stallman in his
friend's code and made windows out of it
this proprietary stuff and then packaged
it and good business man basically for
him poisoned the waterhole and and and
anti-viral software right that was his
thing you can only sell so many
computers but you can you can get a lot
of viruses out of those computers so you
know i i want you to get that software
going you wonder over and over you you
wonder why it is that so many computer
viruses exist sometimes
because
you know nobody's going to my
neighborhood and just randomly attacking
people not not every neighborhood but
we we don't see
you know maybe it's not as easy to say
these days but you don't see overt
political terrorism in the united states
to a great degree like you do in other
parts of the world
and
when you see computers being so often
attacked you have to wonder what the
motivation is and why why don't people
in public engage in this to a cert the
same degree maybe it's as simple as they
do the same amount of people commit
crimes as make viruses but viruses can
spread more and do more damage and
that's why we see it more often but it
is a lucrative business so i certainly
wonder how many of these companies back
in the days anti-virus companies making
the viruses
well we're like uh antifa window repair
like ryan long's comedy sketch
guys go around smashing windows and then
come back the next day and say right
window repair it's not a new tactic it's
why do you buy a 70 000 pickup that has
plastic parts inside the air conditioner
and when it goes out after 30 000 miles
it costs 1800 for somebody to take the
dashboard apart and fix the five dollar
plastic part they know it's gonna wear
out they know you're gonna have to come
in and get it fixed and they keep get
they keep more and more money coming out
of your pocket it's it that's the oldest
trick in the book sell somebody
something that looks great but it has
some kind of flaw that you know they're
gonna have to get it fixed oh by the way
we're the only ones that can fix it or
avoid your warranty that's a busted
system yeah absolutely planned
obsolescence yeah and and disordered
yeah yeah and and what we hear is uh
well that's capitalism off what the left
says and i look at this this like you
know if you want to have if you want to
believe that capitalism can be
idealistic feel free to believe that
it's not true you're gonna find people
who sell snake oil yeah the slave trade
was capitalist too right there's bad
things so
you know when when i hear people say
laissez faire capitalism free markets
are better and all that i'm like i don't
i don't agree i agree a free a freer
market is better but i don't think well
that's the thing about the free market
they say they call it a quote free
market but that doesn't mean anything
about what they say it's just a name
it's like when they say here let's have
a happy kids bill that congress wants to
pass about like punishing a bunch of
bunch of kids you know uh free trade is
not like anyone can do whatever they
want it's heavily regulated only certain
people can do it no no but i'm talking
about a true fair free market where
you know uh buyer be aware kavet and tor
people are are there's a lot of good
arguments i've heard about how
competition will solve a lot of these
issues but you also will get uh planned
obsolescence the counter argument to
that is well then the company that makes
the better light bulb that lasts forever
will will sell more but then my argument
to that is what if one person discovers
the creation you know invents the light
bulb and then
they're making it and other people
haven't figured it out for 10 years so
they create planned obsolescence and
what's what's to say that the other
companies don't just say well why would
i step on the toes of a guy who's
figured out how to get people to buy
light bulbs non-stop why wouldn't they
just say i'm going to do his same
business and just lie to customers and
say it's better yeah oh no you go now
what do you think big pharma is
i mean healthy patients don't make them
any money and dead patients don't make
them any money but patients that we're
keeping alive make a lot of money thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8 00 pm
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website
where we are unrestricted in what we
talk about so you'll definitely not want
to miss it thanks for hanging out we'll
see you all next time
you